[Music]
it's thanksgiving turkey stuffing mashed
potatoes but the one thing that has
always stood out is a bit of a head
scratcher sweet potato casserole
we're pretty sure sweet potatoes and
marshmallows weren't at the original
thanksgiving so what happened sweet
potatoes have been around forever in
marshmallows this sticky gooey mess
actually comes from a plant and has been
around since ancient egypt a delicacy
only pharaohs could eat okay fast
forward to the 20th century marshmallows
were a big deal expensive and
essentially the chris doll of sweet
treats and not only that but they were
even handmade marshmallows became a
mainstay for high falutin housewives see
back then housewives would have to make
whipped cream or even meringue by hand
but the marshmallows were a modern time
saver the first recipe that paired sweet
potatoes and marshmallows appeared in
1918 in a trade journal cleverly named
sweet potatoes and yams
as marshmallows grew in popularity and
began being mass-produced more and more
recipes began implementing them as an
everyday ingredient
nowadays marshmallows are generally
reserved for campfires and hot chocolate
and this non-traditional traditional
favorite whether you like your sweet
potatoes a marshmallow or plain happy
thanksgiving
[Music]
the very thought of thanksgiving drums
up foods worth salivating over like
stuffing mashed potatoes and of course
the tope ferki
but this thanksgiving veggie substitute
wasn't just whipped up overnight it
actually took years of trial and error
so we called the guy who invented it
i am seth tibbett and i am the inventor
of tofurky seth tibbett was living in
oregon he was a teacher and a
self-professed hippie who lived
somewhere shall we say unusual i built
my own three-story tree house out of
scavenged wood he was also a serious
vegetarian so serious that he started
his very own tempe making company and i
made soy tempeh five grain tempeh and a
sausage tempeh called temperoni and i
just made tempeh for the first 15 years
but there was a problem which was
finding something to eat at my own
thanksgiving you see at the time there
were no main dishes for vegetarians
available
so seth set out to solve the problem and
it wasn't so easy first he created a
stuffed pumpkin uh the stuffed pumpkin
was the famous one that we still talk
about the whole thing on the pumpkin was
that it collapsed in the oven and it
seemed more like a side dish than a main
dish then there was the gluten roast
which was really an all day thing took
like eight hours literally it was just
too tough to cut with any kind of
implement that we had
other than a chainsaw which we did not
bring to the table eventually seth
teamed up with his friend hans he was
making these tofu
roasts had a little bit of gravy in
there with them we've added the
drumettes because we were mimicking the
turkey and marketed it under the name
tofurkey
throughout the years the recipe evolved
we soon realized that this is a vegan
feast and vegan plants don't have legs
so
yeah it's been a long journey long
strange tempeh trip as a hippie would
say and now around here we call turkey a
tofurky substitute
[Music]
i can imagine us having thanksgiving
wherever we are in our universe you know
whether it's
pluto mars the moon or wherever i think
as we explore as a civilization we'll
take our traditions with us and break
bread in that same way
i spent thanksgiving in space on my
second space shuttle mission in 2009
there were seven astronauts total we
were like around a campfire with no
campfire but floating in the air
my thanksgiving meal was irradiated
smoked turkey
we had thermally stabilized cornbread
dressing
rehydrated green beans
and oh my goodness these uh other kind
of crazy like kind of candy yams
we always play with our food in space so
i think maybe a green bean or two was
floated over and you you know catch the
green bean it was pretty cool
off the planet you're in this incredible
community of explorers
and that was one thing that i really
felt so connected to is these people
that i'm breaking bread with and being
thankful for on thanksgiving day i'm
sure the pilgrims or the native
americans probably never would have
imagined
turkey in space thanksgiving on mars
would be you know similar to being on
the space station except for your food
wouldn't be floating around because
there's 1 6g on mars so you know
one-sixth of the gravitational pull on
planet earth you would have your
irradiated smoke turkey on the table
sitting there not floating away
[Music]
people need to understand that all of
north america is indigenous land it is
native land
people tend to forget that there was a
vibrant native culture
living in all parts of north america and
food is really the piece that's going to
help us move forward into a brighter
future
my name is sean sherman and i am a chef
i own the company the sous chef
so this is going to be two pieces per
plate for these our mission is
revitalizing native american foods and
re-identifying north american cuisine
we've tried really hard to maintain
authenticity by removing all of the
colonial ingredients like dairy wheat
flour processed sugar beef pork chicken
and we're just using a lot of wild game
a lot of the native agricultural
heirloom varietals a lot of the wild
foods around us and really making those
plates that taste like a region
most of these ingredients are very
familiar to people but the usage of a
lot of the wild plants really talk about
a place in a community
[Music]
we prioritize purchasing from the
indigenous vendors first because we
really want to open up a lot of
opportunity for indigenous people
growing out farms or collecting things
from the wild or raising animals so for
the big dinner we're actually cooking
this bison down with a bunch of fresh
cedar and some bergamot we will purchase
from anybody raising these indigenous
pieces because it is such an important
part of the landscape in the history you
know you want it
[Music]
as we travel around the country we like
to make dinners and foods that really
represent those areas
what's great about being able to do
these dinners especially
in non-indigenous communities is just to
bring awareness this kind of food that
we're eating today like you're going to
feel really good when you leave here
you're not going to feel heavy and
weighted down you're going to feel
energized and just happy because you're
knowing where this food is coming from
we feel like
anybody across north america will
benefit from the understanding of the
indigenous food systems around you and
it's all going to help us move forward
[Music]
there's lots of amazing food in the
philippines but there's one amazing
culinary tradition that's big enough to
feed an army
hi i'm jack and i own buddha fight
manila poodle boodle what what's a
buddha fight
[Applause]
a good fight is a feast set up on banana
leaves just a food pile in the middle
with everyone standing shoulder to
shoulder
and the best part is everyone eats with
their bare hands
it originated with the philippine
military soldiers took the practice home
and it went mainstream
so mainstreamed that chefs like jaff now
have full-time jobs bringing buddle
fights to the masses
the bootle fight is a quintessential
example of how filipinos value sharing
especially when it comes to food
a lot of food is needed for woodland
pride to be enjoyed the way it's meant
to be
we love balintawak market this is where
buddha fight comes together
we'll be needing the essentials pork
chicken seafood
veggies dessert the sides and of course
the fruits and do not forget the start
of the show the banana leaves
i am full already
we start with the messy part the
grilling first the pork
chicken
the seafood and then you slice the
fruits steam the veggies together with
the shrimp and the crab and then slice
all the sides and prepare the table
after setting up the banana leaves it is
important to look for the center of the
table and start from there
you can place the dessert and fruits
then on both sides start with the rice
pork chicken and seafood to make it
extra delicious add the sides literally
on the side of the table the philippines
has a lot of choices when it comes to
food
but none compared to the community that
develops when sharing a pile of food
bare-handed with the people you love
[Music]
cakes cookies and brownies no we're not
going to show you how to make them
because they can be made with ease
thanks to betty crocker who was born in
1921 in minnesota
well kind of
[Music]
in 1921 the washburn crosby company now
known as general mills ran a contest for
people to complete a puzzle for the most
coveted prize a pincushion yes one of
your very own
surprisingly a lot of people wrote in to
claim their prize but with a little ps
how do i make my sponges how much
they wanted baking advice
so the customer service department began
to reply and to make their tips seem
more genuine they signed their letters
betty crocker
betty because it was a cheery all-around
american sounding name and crocker after
a board member
not being a real person didn't stop
betty crocker from having a very
successful radio show the betty crocker
cooking school of the air
with a different accent in every state
[Music]
betty crocker cooking
but the lies don't stop there let's talk
about that added ingredient the egg
you don't need to add a fresh egg to
powdered cake mix but science says it
makes us feel like we aren't cheating
and we're better providers
so thanks betty crocker for making us
all feel like we know how to bake
[Music]